mehr als 1000 inseln liegen im sankt
lorenz strom
ihre schönheit und ihre legenden
faszinieren die menschen seit
jahrhunderten
vom wasser und aus der luft sind die am
besten zu entdecken
die unzähligen felsbrocken sind kleine
wunder der natur
[Musik]
1000 islands heißt eine der
beeindruckendsten regionen im norden des
amerikanischen kontinents im grenzgebiet
von kanada und den usa
mitten im sankt-lorenz-strom die
entdeckung des archipels beginnt in
kanada dem tor zu den 1000 inseln kurz
vor tagesanbruch auf dem kleinen
flugplatz vor der stadt
das ist der ausgangspunkt zu einem
rundflug über die 1000 inseln heute
begrüßt chef pilot john de mol den
bekanntesten fotografen der regierung
ihren kurs team
guten morgen jordan bereit nicht zu
terrorisieren
das team hat seit jahren eine
leidenschaft und ein motiv die 1000
inseln von oben viel ist selbst pilot
heute bestimmt er die flugroute dann
zurück zur singer kassel was immer
bezaubernd ist und auf dem rückweg
vorbei an bord kassel muss sehen was wir
da anrichten können
[Musik]
die beiden männer sind ein eingespieltes
team ihn sucht die motive aus und jordan
sorgt für die geeignete perspektive
jordan verpflegung vorbereitet
[Musik]
sobald es hell wird starten sie ohne
vorher genau zu wissen ob sich ein flug
lohnt nur eins ist sicher die schönsten
bilder bekommen sie früh am morgen
frühstücks nicht du schläfst nicht aus
du verpasst die cocktail stunde kein
abendessen vielleicht ein sandwich
spätnachts diesen aspekt mochte ich nie
aber wenn du dann mit einem schatz nach
hause kommst dann war es das alles wert
[Musik]
die 1000 inseln die in wahrheit 1864
sind verteilen sich auf gut 80
kilometern auf den sankt lorenz strom
der form ontario see bis zum atlantik
fließt
eins ist sicher du kommst nie ans ende
es gibt immer eine ecke biegen noch
nicht erforscht hast du denkst du hast
alles gesehen weil du darüber geflogen
ist aber in wahrheit ist dass einer
dieser orte nicht groß aber groß genug
mit dem du nie
[Musik]
auf seinen flügen entdeckt die ehe nicht
nur die schönheit der 1000 inseln er hat
auch ein neues zuhause gefunden
gemeinsam mit seiner frau ist er auf dem
weg zur eigenen insel
sein wunsch hier zu leben ist mit den
jahren immer stärker geworden
doch als pilot braucht er einen festen
landeplatz und einen hangar für sein
flugzeug
[Musik]
kann sein traum hier überhaupt wahr
werden die inseln sind alle aus granit
und mit kiefern bestanden
du kannst nicht einfach ein flugzeug auf
ihnen parken und dann fand ich diesen
ort mit dem naturhafen der genau eine
flügelspannweite ist ich habe wirklich
nachgemessen und tatsächlich es passte
nur die flügel lappen über die saiten
ein flugzeug parkplatz direkt vom haus
auf der insel sicher wie in einem hangar
nur eben ohne dach
im sommer liegt ihnen die meiste zeit
hier nach dem mythos der amerikanischen
ureinwohner ließ der große geist
himmlische blütenblätter regnen und
verwandelte den fluss so in einen
göttlichen karten zwei drittel der
inseln gehören zu kanada ein drittel zu
den usa
[Musik]
eine der bekanntesten inseln ist da
island zwei seemeilen von der
amerikanischen küste entfernt hier steht
das sagenumwobene märchenschloss sänger
karsai jedes jahr im april wenn nach
einem langen winter der fluss auftaut
und das eis zu schmelzen beginnt kehrt
das leben auf die insel zurück dann wird
auch zynga kassel aus seinem
dornröschenschlaf geweckt
[Musik]
hausmeisters gott garris und sein helfer
öffnet das schloss für die sommersaison
1903 wurde es nach dem vorbild eines
englischen jagdschlosses aus dem
achtzehnten jahrhundert erbaut
michael ist es steinernes zeugnis einen
eher wohlhabendsten epochen nordamerikas
[Musik]
bevor ende april die ersten besucher
kommen müssen es gott und seine helfer
alles herrichten
wir brauchen zwei wochen bis das schloss
eröffnet werden kann
reparaturarbeiten verlängern die zeit
ein bisschen es kommt auf das wetter an
draußen geht es etwas langsamer voran es
regnet oder schneit arbeiten wir einfach
immer weiter
[Musik]
die insel ist nur mit dem ausflugsboot
zu erreichen bis zu 25.000 besucher sind
es jedes jahr die das geheimnisvolle
schloss erkunden wollen
es ist das einzige auf den 1000 inseln
das je fertig gebaut möbliert und
bezogen wurde
auftraggeber von singer kassel war der
präsident der sänger nähmaschinenfabrik
ein business superstar seinerzeit und
damals einer der reichsten männer der
welt
frederic j born
im winter ist es hier der hausherr und
er ist auch der einzige bewohner der das
ganze jahr über in seiner kasse liegt
[Musik]
das wird man dreizehnter sommer hier
ich liebe es wir sind den ganzen sommer
beschäftigt mit übernachtungsgästen und
touristen
und wenn der winter kommt mag ich die
ruhige zeit weil ich dann eine menge
arbeit erledigen kann zu der ich nicht
komme wenn gäste das schloss besichtigen
fast alle räume sind den besuchern
zugänglich
doch nur wenige ahnen welche geheimnisse
sich hier verbergen
genau hier ist eine tür zu unserem
geheimgänge sie lässt sich mit dem
kleiderhaken öffnen hochziehen und
reindrücken
ich gehe hinein mache das licht an und
sie folgen dem trabi
[Musik]
da hingehe wie in einem märchenschloss
tatsächlich hatten sie einen ganz
praktischen nutzen verriet born nutzte
die gänge für sein personal damit es für
die gäste unsichtbar blieb jeder würde
gerne hier hoch kommen aber nicht alle
dürfen das
die idee für bonns schloss lieferte die
beliebte novelle woodstock von server
des gott und er ein schloss aus dem 17
jahrhundert beschreibt mit geheimen
gängen und glockenturm jeden herbst am
ende der saison stoppe ich die uhr für
den winter um 6 uhr 30 so dass beide
zeiger nach unten zeigen so muss ich mir
keine gedanken machen dass sich eis und
schnee auf ihnen türmen und sie
abbrechen und im frühling starte ich sie
wieder für die neue saison
in den langen wintermonaten sieht gott
oft wochenlang keinen menschen
normalerweise bin ich hier sechs bis
sieben wochen eingefroren diesen winter
war am 4
die letzten zwei jahre waren es eher 9
bis 10 ich hatte übernachtungsgäste und
touristen die sagen dass sie dinge
gesehen haben
aber es gab nie einen beweis für
irgendwas hier spukt es nicht nur der
hausmeister
[Musik]
der winter hat die region oft bis in den
april fest im griff
auch in kanada april in der kleinen
stadt auf dem kanadischen festland
warten die bewohner sehnsüchtig auf den
saisonbeginn nur ein paar unermüdliche
zieht es in dieser jahreszeit ans wasser
[Musik]
für die bootsbauer von kanal ok group
schützen und ihren chef mike oregon ist
das die beste zeit um in ruhe ihrer
arbeit nachzugehen dem restaurieren
alter holzboote die meisten boote um die
sich mike kümmert sind schon seit
generationen in familienbesitz und an
sankt lorenz strom gebaut worden
viele über 100 jahre alt das ist ein
ganz schönes chaos
meistens muss er die boote erst völlig
auseinander nehmen bis er sie wieder
aufbauen können
[Musik]
hier sieht man wie es zu verrotten
begann im bereich muss sich reparieren
da sieht es gut aus wir werden sehen
wann es fertig wird aber es ist ziemlich
nah an 1000 arbeitsstunden
mike hat als banker und verkaufsmanager
gearbeitet
doch mit 35 wechselte er in die
bootsbauer schule und kann sich seitdem
vor aufträgen nicht retten
hier dauert die boots saison zwei monate
plus ein monat im juni und ein im
september wenn du die zwei monate
verpasst hast du zehn monate mehr um an
den burgen zu arbeiten zusammen mit
brooke seine auszubildenden versucht er
trotzdem alle aufträge pünktlich zu
schaffen
wir brauchen mehr schrauben du musst
diese zwei löcher für das nicht gut aus
meine ganze familie lange jahre als
caretaker auf den inseln gearbeitet und
zu den meisten inseln gehörten holzboote
mein großvater hat diese boote in stand
gehalten und als ich klein war habe ich
ihn zugeschaut und eine menge gelernt
ich dachte immer das ist nichts mehr für
meine generation
deshalb ist es jetzt für mich als wäre
ein traum wahr geworden
das ist wirklich toll ich bin sehr
glücklich
das reparieren von alten boden allein
reicht ihnen nicht
die herausforderung sind neue nach altem
vorbild der bekannteste bootstyp der
1000 inseln ist das saint laurents griff
ein einfaches ruderboot aus dem
neunzehnten jahrhundert das extra für
den st lorenz strom entwickelt wurde
inspiriert sind sie von so einem
historischen skiff das wollen sie in ein
paar wochen wieder ins wasser bringen
es ist manchmal sehr emotional mit
tränen und allen es ist etwas was ich
mir immer in erinnerung rufe wenn ich im
tiefen winter im bauch eines bootes
arbeiter dann denke ich an den tag wenn
es wieder ins wasser kommt und sagen wir
es gehört einer familie die es schon
seit generationen besitzt dann ist es
wie ein familienmitglied
und wenn es dann ins wasser kommt sind
alle so gerührt
das ist überwältigend einfach großartig
ein paar kilometer außerhalb von bombay
hat auch george horten jetzt am meisten
zu tun
george ist sie ruppaner und auf dem weg
in seinen shooter busch erntezeit ist
von februar bis april
[Musik]
du brauchst warme tage und kalte nächte
normalerweise willst du plus fünf grad
über den tag und minus 5 über nacht es
lässt die baum säfte am tag steigen und
in der nacht fallen
george muss zuerst die vakuumpumpe
kontrollieren die den baum saft direkt
in einen tank gepumpt so wie george
gewinnen heute viele kanadier an st
heute ist es ein bisschen zu kalt waren
- 8 in der nacht und es sind immer noch
minus 12 grad
vielleicht beginnt es heute nachmittag
zu laufen wenn es wärmer wird
im moment ist es ein bisschen zu kalt
für sagt erste temperaturwechsel bringt
den saft zum fließen
zeit für einen kontrollgang eine meiner
aufgaben ist es durch den bus zu laufen
und nach lecks zu sehen wenn ich eins
finde muss ich es reparieren
die plastik leitungen führen direkt vom
baum zur pumpe wenn ein leck in der
leitung ist kommt luft hinein und dann
verliere ich das vakuum im system
[Musik]
für einen liter ahornsirup sind zwischen
30 und 50 liter baums oft nötig früher
lief der einfach aus einem zapfhahn in
einen eimer am baum
[Musik]
es gibt tatsächlich richtlinien wie viel
saft man zapfen darf das hängt vom baum
hier vertragen einen zapfhahn manche 2
da aber ein paar richtig alte bäume 2
300 jahren eigentlich 4 zopf für eine
anbringen lassen auf dass es nicht zu
viel lässt denn du kannst den baum
schaden oder ihn umbringen wenn du ihn
nicht richtig behandelt
doch jobs versteht sein handwerk
er ist in der sechsten generation sirup
pharma- und der wald seit 1836 in
familienbesitz
wenn er seinen kindern den sugar busch
vermacht
dann soll er in einem guten zustand sein
mit starken gesunden bäumen
von den dreieinhalbtausend bäumen die
ihr hier anzapfen könnte beschränkt er
sich deshalb auf 600 ist wirklich
ziemlich süß war ein sehr süßes ja man
kann die qualität feststellen wenn man
den saft trinkt und interessanterweise
haben die bäume eine unterschiedliche
qualität und einen unterschiedlichen
zuckergehalt manchmal haben ältere bäume
mehr saft es variiert von wald zu wald
aber auch von baum zu baum und von
saison zu saison
george fan ist an die 170 hektar groß
gut 18 davon gehören zum ahorn wald
früher hatte er auch milchkühe heute
baut er nur noch getreide an und macht
im frühling zero zwischen 240 und 480
liter ahornsirup produziert ihr im jahr
eine eher durchschnittliche menge doch
george ist die qualität wichtiger als
die quantität der saft läuft vom tank
direkt in den kessel und dann wird
gekocht
es ist ein sehr süßes krieger und
erdiger geruch etwas das man nur im
frühling riechen kann einfach der beste
geruch der welt
der saft wird so pur wie er aus dem baum
kommt eingekocht dauer und temperatur
entscheiden über das fertige produkt
zeigt die temperatur die ich erreichen
will
wasser kocht bei 212 grad fahrenheit ich
will es sieben grad heiße haben weil ich
glaube dass das die qualität des
ahornsirup verbessert
je länger der sirup kocht umso dunkler
wird er und umso konzentrierter ist der
zuckergehalt den mist das refraktometer
ein brauer in ghana noch wartet schon
auf eine lieferung mit dunklen sierung
alles läuft nach plan
gelegenheit für eine kleine pause im ein
mann betrieb
[Musik]
wenn die april sonne das land und den
fluss langsam auftaut wird es für burn
fielding und don't go zeit auf den
inseln vor kann an ob wayne nach dem
rechten zu sehen
die beiden sind cottage caretaker und
dafür verantwortlich dass die insel
häuser die nur im sommer bewohnt werden
in ordnung sind
sie halten sie den winter über entstand
und öffnen sie im frühjahr für die
familie
doch erst mal müssen sie ihr boot
startklar machen
so ist das kalt naja ich weiß ich habe
auch einen rausgezogen aus dem kleineren
roth
bei einer wassertemperatur knapp über
null sind sie heute die einzigen auf dem
fluss ein ausflug der nicht ungefährlich
ist
doch bernhard 25 jahre erfahrung in dem
geschäft
früher war er mal banker und neun monate
im jahr auf reisen
aber als er seine frau kennenlernte
wurde er hier sesshaft und kümmert sich
seitdem um die cottagers sein partner
dawn ist seit fünf jahren dabei
das sieht gut aus
die bank war nur ein job satt werden das
hier ist legen die beiden kümmern sich
um zwölf coaches von stammkunden sowie
auf matt lanter island seit 1875 wird
sie von derselben familie bewohnt
[Musik]
ja ok sie müssten es mal streichen
lassen stand überhaupt keinen schwung
drin das ist gut das ist wahrscheinlich
mehr die verschalung die weiße kiefer
wird ein bisschen war ich wahrscheinlich
müssen wir bereiche rausschneiden oder
wir verdoppeln es auch in münchen
stellen ich bin nicht sicher wie weit
sie gehen wollen
das ist ein altes erbstück mit all
seinen eigenheiten und macken
träumen sie manchmal von einer eigenen
insel auf einer insel zu arbeiten ist
eine echte herausforderung weil alles
mit dem boot her und auf dem berg
gebracht werden muss jedes mal wenn ich
mit der arbeit fertig bin bin ich
ziemlich froh nach hause zu kommen
glücklicherweise lebe ich direkt am
wasser ich wünsche mir keine eigene
insel
ich bin hier hergekommen hat mich in den
fluss verliebt und das boot fahren
es ist als wäre man auf einer kreuzfahrt
du bist draußen
du hast keine nachrichten keine
zeitungen hat leute die reden es ist
sehr friedlich
ich vermisse überhaupt nichts außerdem
hält es dich fit außer im winter wenn
wir fett werden
[Musik]
auch innen kontrollieren sie das
sommerhaus manchmal gibt es schäden die
der winter angerichtet hat oder tiere
die eindringen
für sie ist der kontrollgang durch das
alte coach auch eine reise in eine
vergangene zeit
mit der ein oder anderen entdeckung
da ist die alte besitzurkunde über den
landverkauf da ist noch eine das sind
die original besitzt urkunden die die
krone nach dem krieg 1812 ausgestellt
ist dieser typ
ich schätze dass es der alte briten dem
der besitz gehörte das cottage hat auch
diesen winter gut überstanden
lasst uns gehen
viele coaches leiden im winter unter der
extremen witterung auf ihrer fahrt über
den fluss darf ihnen nichts entgegen
[Musik]
auf die männer wartet noch ein auftrag
ein bewohner von kaster bieker island
hat ein neues bootshaus bestellt
er lebt drei stunden entfernte toronto
und kommt erst eines warm wird auch wenn
die häuser komfortabel aussehen im
winter kann man hier nicht leben
das größte problem um das ganze jahr
hier zu leben ist dass die häuser kein
fundament haben
das heißt sie kühlen aus der boden ist
nicht vor kälte geschützt so frieren die
wasserleitungen ein und es gibt probleme
mit dem abwasser dem wasser und vor
allem der kälte ich meine man kann die
häuser heizen aber das ist sehr teuer
und die andere sache ist wenn um dich
herum alles eis ist kommst du nicht weg
das eis wird nie dick genug
man kann es nicht betreten mit dem
bootshaus haben sie einen lukrativen
großauftrag an land gezogen es bleiben
noch sechs wochen bis es warm wird
die verkleidung die wände und das dach
bauen wir in zwei wochen
so haben wir noch viel zeit es fertig zu
stellen meistens wenn das wetter ein
paar tage schlecht ist dann holen wir
die zeit am wochenende nach so wird es
auf jeden fall rechtzeitig fertig
auch ein paar kilometer weiter
flussabwärts auf hill island laufen die
saisonvorbereitungen auf hochtouren
das markanteste gebäude ist hier kein
cottage sondern ein aussichtsturm
der höchste punkt der region von dem aus
man den besten überblick über die inseln
hat der 1001 tower ist ein echtes
wahrzeichen
er liegt auf der kanadischen seite nur
wenige hundert meter von der us
amerikanischen grenze entfernt
[Musik]
als er vor drei jahren zum verkauf stand
haben heidi und konrad link ein
deutsches auswanderer ehepaar
zugegriffen
[Applaus]
das den winter überstanden hat also das
ist leider dann doch gebrochen
ich werde es jetzt noch mal anwenden
aber für den rest der saison brauchen
wir dann neues ich würde ja gerne als
ganzes schild neu machen diese ganze
schild anlage neu machen ja und ich
hätte gerne so eine elektrische
anzeigetafel dafür da unsere specials
und special event hin schreiben können
okay
das heißt wir müssen den strom hier
irgendwie bereitstellen kann schon das
nicht mit solar machen
das gilt batterie und spannungswandler
noch ist der turm für die besucher
geschlossen und heidi und konrad mitten
in den vorbereitungen für die kommende
saison
das ganze gelände gehörte in den 60er
jahren zu einem vergnügungspark übrig
geblieben ist nur der 138 meter hohe
koloss aus beton und stahl
das ist eine absolute exoten immobilie
wo es eigentlich keine daten zu gibt was
es kostet was schiefgehen kann für uns
gibt es dann für die mittlere zukunft
zwei meilensteine einmal wenn wir so
viel geld verdient hätten dass wir
jederzeit den fahrstuhl komplett neu
bezahlen könnten oder die gesamte
immobilie abbezahlt ist das liegt noch
in der zukunft wir sind auf einem guten
weg dahin auch dank der aufgelösten
lebensversicherung begeistert von dem
tool und ich hab immer gedacht wir
können uns noch keinen punkt kaufen das
ist ja verrückt und ich habe so viel
marketing gemacht für hotels und und
andere gesellschaften dass ich gedacht
okay ich muss ja jetzt mal drüber
nachdenken und dann kam ich an und habe
gesagt weißt du was das gute an dem turm
ist keiner baut einen zweiten tod
also wir haben keine konkurrenz was
dieses produkt angeht und keiner fragt
mich ob ich den preis besser machen kann
weil es ja keiner günstiger anbieten
kann
und das war dann für mich darf ausschlag
geben dazu sagen lasst uns das versuchen
doch geld verdienen sie hier nur im
sommer das gebäude der turm das war
immer als saisongeschäft geplant und es
war immer quasi ein sommergeschäft das
heißt das komplette gebäude ist nicht
gegen die kälte geschützt das heißt die
wasserleitungen frieren ein wenn es
draußen minus 20 grad ist es drinnen
auch minus 20 grad und deshalb können
wir das geschäft nicht betreiben
erstaunlichen umsatz machen sie mit
souvenirs vor allem die besucher aus den
usa fragen immer wieder nach diesem
einen kanadischen produkt und unsere
besondere spezialität porzellan von den
royals
wir hatten nie geglaubt dass es dafür
eine große kundschaft gibt aber es gibt
leute die sagen ihr habt ja eine königin
wo ist das porzellan mit der königin
braucht um finanziell über die runden zu
kommen brauchen sie mindestens 22.000
besucher im jahr
ich wurde als kind immer auf den
höchsten punkt geschickt wenn wir
irgendwo urlaub gemacht haben oder wenn
wir ein sonntagsausflug gemacht hat man
ist immer auf die kirchturmspitze und
hat sich umgeschaut das ist eine typisch
deutsche art finde ich und das merkt man
den deutschen an die wollen das ganze
von oben sehen die möchten nicht nur die
bootstour machen die möchten dass
tatsächlich von oben sehen werden die
amerikaner die haben ja diese kultur
nicht die wissen manchmal gar nicht was
sie mit dem tor machen soll
die treppe ist nur für den notfall 396
stufen führen hinauf besucher nehmen den
lift und werden oben mit einer sicht
belohnt die bei gutem wetter kilometer
weit über die inseln reicht natürlich
auch über die inseln auf der anderen der
us amerikanischen seite des stroms
auch der homestead farm geht es
inzwischen hektisch zu der sirup ist
gekocht und george hat alle hände voll
zu tun ihn ab zu finden
[Musik]
in der regel bekomme ich so zwischen 80
und 120 gallonen heraus dieses jahr war
verrückt 125 gallonen dabei eine woche
in der zucker hütte gelebt
[Musik]
schon die erntesaison war ungewöhnlich
lang george erledigt alles alleine und
in handarbeit auch das abfüllen 12
dollar kostet dieser halbliterflasche
den ahorn sirup vermarktet ihr direkt
auf der farm und beliefert kleine läden
in der umgebung den großauftrag für die
brauerei in kanal ok liefert er
natürlich persönlich aus
der brauer hatte ihn gleich kanister
weise bestellt
bruce george ahornsirup bio ich freue
mich drauf
er ist ja noch war ja direkt aus der
produktion das ist toll
ich denke das wird ein gutes bier können
wir den probieren ja was uns den giro
probieren
ich glaube das ist er jetzt erst
wirklich dunkel
ja es gibt mehr geschmack schön dunkel
so wie du es habe schau dir diese farbe
schön dunkel bernstein
ich glaube der ist genau der richtige
für sein bier george das ist großartig
guter geschmack war es ja toll
beim ersten versuch war bloß gescheitert
doch das lag natürlich nicht am sirup
sondern eher am rezept
[Musik]
zwei monate später ist die
wintertristesse wie weggeblasen
mit den warmen sonnenstrahlen kehrt das
leben auf die 1001 zurück ab juni
besuchen sie nicht nur die reichen
sommergäste sondern auch die
inselbewohner kommt wieder nach hause
die schwankende einwohnerzahl sie ist
typisch für die 1000 in sein
[Musik]
auch die insel von fotografien christin
ist nur in den sommermonaten bewohnbar
noch immer erforschten die region mit
seiner kamera und ist fasziniert von der
schönheit und der magie der 1000 inseln
dabei war es nur ein zufall dass er sie
überhaupt gefunden hat ich habe in der
nähe von montreal gewohnt anderthalb
stunden westlich von ihr
ich war im flugzeuggeschäft und habe
flugzeuge verkauft mein flugzeug hatte
schwimmer und eines tages dachte ich
nehme ein paar freunde mit und starrte
in ein kleines abenteuer
wir hoben westlich von montreal ab und
anderthalb stunden später sah ich dieses
außergewöhnliche unglaubliche archipel
aus granit und kiefern dem wasser natur
und schlösser
ich war überwältigt und konnte nicht
glauben was ich sah wie hatte so etwas
außergewöhnliches mein ganzes leben so
nah sein können und ich wusste es nicht
so begann eine suche die drei jahre
dauerte bis sich schließlich der
glücklichste mensch der welt wurde als
sich diese insel fand ich machte fotos
und zeigte sie meinen freunden weil die
nicht glaubten was ich entdeckt hatte
nein es ist wahr sagte ich seht wie
schön es ist und dann verstanden sie und
drängten mich etwas mit denen fotos zu
machen und es entwickelte sich eine
karriere die ich nie erwartet oder
geplant hatte ich war völlig
unvorbereitet ich bin sehr glücklich
dass alles so geklappt hat
sieben bildbände über die 1000 inseln
hat ihn schon veröffentlicht viele davon
preisgekrönt das wasserflugzeug hat er
längst verkauft und immer noch findet er
neue blicke und perspektiven auf den
fluss auf direkt von der eigenen insel
aus
der sankt-lorenz-strom hat sie beide in
seinen bann geschlagen
[Musik]
und auch die insel ist ihn nicht mehr
los
[Musik]
eine sache die mich an dieser insel
wirklich fasziniert hat ist das direkt
hier an der küste ein dorf der
ureinwohner
ich dachte immer ich musste auch einen
beweis dafür finden aber eines tages kam
ein parkranger vorbei er sagte du musst
keine artefakte finden um sicher zu sein
alles was du tun musst ist dir diese
kreise hier im felsen anzusehen
die sind durch lagerfeuer entstanden die
die obere schicht auf platzen ließen
das würde tausende von jahren dauern bis
die erosion sie wieder glatt schleift
und als ich das hörte war ich wirklich
fasziniert
[Musik]
der fluss sucht die menschen aus das ist
ein so besonderer ort nicht gefangen
nimmt hat er dich dann kannst du nicht
mehr entkommen
[Musik]
auch in den hafen von cannes an ok sind
die schiffs- und insel besitzer
zurückgekehrt zeit die alten holzboote
von mike wieder ins wasser zu lassen
das gilt pot von 1909 ist als erstes an
der reihe
den ganzen winter über haben sie daran
gearbeitet noch ein paar letzte
handgriffe und es ist bereit für die
jungfernfahrt
wir machen es fertig und schließen die
lens pumpe die sehr wichtig ist wir
werden es auf dem wasser in gurten
halten zwar dass es schwimmt und das
holz aufquillt undicht wird und
hoffentlich läuft alles nach plan
eigentlich routine für den erfahrenen
bootsbauer doch noch zehn monaten in der
werkstatt ist das gift völlig
ausgetrocknet in brennans marine in
kanada gray soll es zum ersten mal
wieder fluss wasser unter den kiel
bekommen
[Musik]
vor allem für max lehrling brooke ist
das ein aufregender tag
[Musik]
dies war das erste boot an dem ich
gearbeitet habe als ich bei mike
anfängen deshalb ist es schön zu sehen
dass es jetzt ins wasser kommt aber es
ist auch ein bisschen traurig wenn man
monatelang an einem boot arbeitet es ist
schwer ist einen kunden zurückzugeben
es war einfach so viel arbeit die
sicherungsmaßnahmen sind chefsache
es ist immer ein guter tag ein boot zu
wasser zu lassen indem man das ganze
jahr gearbeitet hat besonders wenn man
so große reparaturen hatte wie hier
es ist ein bisschen besorgniserregend
aber ich bin sicher dass es gut geht und
dann ist der moment gekommen
wie kanada
geht weiter
alles gut wir sind frei das über 100
jahre alte chefcoach wind doch wird es
auch über wasser bleiben sie auch gut ja
genau hier läuft ich habe noch nie ein
droht so schnell verlaufen sehen wie
dieses es ist beängstigend ich meine das
holzschild meistens arm und wird
schließlich wasserdicht aber wenn man
sieht wie das wasser hinein strömten
zuerst angst aber ich habe vertrauen
dass es durchkommt
und auch marc ist zuversichtlich schon
den ruf ihrer wegen bevor das aluminium
und fiberglas boote gab musstest du dass
jedes jahr machen wenn du ein cottage
hattest und kein boot
du konntest nicht einfach eins ins
wasser lassen und losfahren
es brauchte ein bisschen pflege du musst
es das brot aufquellen lassen bis du es
nutzen konntest du hattest eine handvoll
vorbereitung jedes jahr so dass du
wirklich mit einem boot verbunden war
glaube ich aber vielleicht sage ich das
auch nur weil ich bin
der sankt-lorenz-strom ist für die
großen containerschiffe und tanker einer
der wichtigsten transportwege um waren
vom atlantik bis zu den großen seen zu
schiffen den kleinen holzbooten werden
sie trotz der enge nicht gefährlich an
bord sind speziell ausgebildete lotsen
die den weg zwischen den untiefen im
strom genau kennen
ihr weg führt auch dicht vorbei an dark
eilen
hier steht singer kassel das private
schloss kann für hochzeiten oder eine
übernachtung gemietet werden
im sommer ist es eines der beliebtesten
ausflugsziele für touristen über 20.000
gäste besuchen das über 100 jahre alte
schloss im jahr
[Musik]
der hausherr aus deutschland ist zu
besuchen
der hamburger ver.di hat die insel vor
14 jahren zusammen mit zwei freunden
erworben
mindestens einmal im jahr kommt er für
zwei wochen hierher um nach dem rechten
zu sehen
[Musik]
seine neunjährige tochter valentina ist
zum ersten mal auf tag 100 jahren vor
200 jahren war hier eigentlich gar
nichts diese insel war ein felsen und
dadurch dass der felsen der anhöhe hat
war der felsen auch er hatte ein
schatten abgegeben
und dieser schatten hatte immer irgendwo
diese inseln dunkel gezeigte und aus
diesem grunde nannten die nazis die
insel da teilen die ureinwohner wurden
vor über 150 jahren von den inseln
vertrieben
1902 kaufte forderung born präsident der
singer nähmaschine werke und
multimillionär die insel und ließ das
jagdschloss bauen
das ist hier der eingang zum gehalten
das ist ganz verschluss
[Musik]
da gibt es viele treppen bis nach oben
eine eigene insel zu besitzen davon
träumte der hamburger schon als kleines
kind nichts ahnend dass aus diesem traum
später einmal sein beruf werden fordern
jedes kind in deutschland ließ denn den
robinson crusoe roman liest die
schatzinsel und solche geschehen und so
kam das auch in meinen kopf für eine
insel muss was traumhaftes sein und
dieser gedanke hat mich nicht mehr
losgelassen oder ich suchte nach in
seiner ganzen welt bis ich dann die
inseln gefunden hatte die zu verkaufen
waren aber die waren eine meiner ganzen
preissegment und deshalb habe ich den
gedanken fallengelassen wie eine eigene
insel zu kaufen aber ich dachte meine
gesamten kosten die ich bisher hatte
muss ich irgendwie zurück wollen und
habe dann in hamburg die inseln
angeboten mit erfolg 2006 100 inseln hat
er bis heute auf der ganzen welt
verkauft bell island hat er gerade
zusammen mit fünf partnern von der ralph
lauren familie selbst erworben
auch wenn er sich als immobilienmakler
bezeichnet beim verkauf von inseln
herrschen andere gesetze betreten die
bäume wissen sie ja sehen anders aus und
das ist ungefähr so wie in der chemie
bei den gemälden wenn sie ein gemälde
haben können sie auch nicht nur rubens
bild oder van gogh bild dadurch bemessen
dass sie sagen er hat er 100 gramm farbe
genutzte und deshalb ist das andere bild
soundsoviele dieses bild so und so viel
wert so geht es hier auch nicht mit den
quadratmeter es ist die erscheinung ist
die wie sie die insel empfangen die
gefühle die sich hier entwickeln die
energie und entsprechend ist eigentlich
dann auch der preis
der preis für so eine insel liegt grob
bei einer million euro inklusive hause
mobiliar
[Musik]
farhad vladi verkauft inseln auf der
ganzen welt aber die 1000 inseln sind
für ihn etwas ganz besonderes hier haben
wir ein insel mehr essen eigentlich
alles kleine kunstwerke der natur
praktisch jeder felsen es hier irgendwo
erschlossen das habe ich ganz selten auf
diese erbe die inseln sind sehr stark
verbunden mit familien und es geht mir
hier auch so ich sage immer meiner
familie das letzte was sie hergeben
würde an materiellen gütern ist unsere
insel
und so ist es eigentlich auch in so ist
wie das dritte vierte fünfte kind
familie deswegen verbringt der hamburger
auch so viel zeit wie möglich in dem
inselparadies der 1000 teilens eine der
beeindruckendsten natur landschaften
nordamerikas
[Musik]